I will be talking about how to make
cross cross-platform apps in summer in
forms utilizing 5s as a service backup
so my name is Vernon Johnson and work
for a company called the from max that
established a few months back
don't summer in development for about
three plus years I'm doing some
experimenting and prototyping with
firebase last year and actually is a
project on Summerlin forms and firebase
this spring and okay so justly how many
has its own summary in development okay
not that many
and what about 5s even pure so this is
not a talk about submarine as such
unplayable so just go very briefly
through the concept of that and some
Aryan is a cross-platform development
platform for for Android iOS and windows
Nicola can make if the concept is that
if you share the business object and
then you make traditionally make the UI
specific in for iOS and Android so it
exposes the the fuel API for both
platforms but only get this specific UI
development for a for both platforms
with summer informs you can also do the
UI in in share code either in a salmon
like the annotation or just with the
c-sharp code directly
yeah it's firebase sorry
firebase was
I think you're nice fibers was developed
like 2012 from scented so I started as a
real-time database which is a Jason key
value store you can filter data and
synchronize between flights within
milliseconds and it also supports
offline region each client and work
offline and get synchronized in their
online again it further has more more
features added and was acquired by
Google some years back and last year in
the Google i/o conference it was
announced as the unified platform for
Android iOS and web mobile apps so it
has a really nice set of features to
support mobile and modern mobile apps
also in March this year they announced
the five s functions you can also is
little jesting it's going to open the
another dimensional architectures this
is a tweet contender to our web services
and Azure okay um then we'll do a short
demo I have made a small demo app it
suggests a public chat room and
hopefully the demo guy and I goes all in
there so let me see okay ah let's see if
I can move my cursor over here so this
is the the firebase web console break
oneself up your project and manage your
features the features you want to use so
what we're looking at here is the defy
base with time database it's an empty
database not and we want to use that to
host the necessary now in the chat room
yes just find the other the Android app
okay so then we got summer informs at
and deployed both on an android emulator
and iOS simulator I can try to post
messages and see what happens so the
Android one says anyone here Mitchell
keyboard and then you see it was
reflected in the based on the client and
also push to the the database you can
see the in Gotham and friggin now I'm
get that message and it will synchronize
to the iOS client as well so you can try
to reply on this phone I'm here sorry
yeah close and that was the fish today
to the server and supplies to the other
kind festival
so Diana this looks promising
maybe they can have lunch yeah great
ready for announce something like that
[Music]
unless it's respect then we can try to
see how the the wireless part order them
long or offline mode is supported
circuit turn off the the wireless and
this one got the necessary response site
great
or yeah something like that
so now we see that was reflected on
locally on this client but it's not push
to the database and not synchronized to
the other clients so it's one gigabit
guess not
is also offline so just reflected on
that kind and not synchronize then we
can try to turn the network on again
hopefully that will work is that's a bit
unstable that'll crossing fingers yeah
but those methods are no push to their
to the database and synchronizing both
lines this is quite nice don't look if
the how is this really actually
implemented so turn back to this right
for a moment so if you forget about some
are in for a moment if just saying as
straightforward the app development on
iOS and Android using the native to set
it typically healthy you will put in the
packages for iOS and for Android for
five days and then do the whole
application two separate applications
and duplicate all the logic on both of
them purpose of summer and is to try to
avoid all that application and save some
of the lifecycle cost so some are in in
December they they published firebase
bindings for iOS and Android
however these libraries are very flat
for specific and reflects the languages
used on the platform so ha it's not
straightforward just use those from from
summer in so help me get some
development trying to find a unified the
dotnet API on top of five days to handle
the the motioning of object values the
different mediums on async programming
so it look a bit to that anger but the
result is that we can have a summer
informs application on top as doing all
all you I am all applications knowledge
so it looks a bit overwhelming that's
what this is the nougat packages this is
a generic wrapping application not
specific for the application and this is
what you have to do per application okay
let's have a look at some code see so
this is the this is the solution for
this simple chat app so we have a shared
project or in summer in forms use
containing all all UI and application
logic and we have a services project to
communicate with this unify the API so
we should just start from the top this
is the this is the main application
because it has some observer collection
all messages
let's book net kind of observable
collection and it has just a main page
containing this list of messages and two
input fields for name and the message on
a post button
so this ListView binds to the messages
collection under myself up observing
messages from the from the server and
that is it's quite simple so we have
this we have a data service on top of
this unified API maybe say that we want
to observe messages doesn't have to type
of event we can you can have a new and
entity added to the collection or an
entity renews and then the update is a
local collection according
and then we have the post a new message
we also get this data service and just
post a message okay and then we can look
at this so this is there the whole UI on
the handing over the view model if we go
into this services project we have a it
has a d0 for the message so it's just
got the three properties a name text on
a date and it inherits from an
identifiable that is the the only
concept we need to know about on this
unified API it's because the whole the
model of the firebase written database
is a key value store so this identify
the whole the key and it can be any type
of banyak in addition to that and then
we have the providers providers is
actually this unified API so it's a
generic interface taking a type and then
you can create delete entities of that
site against the collection in 5s
database you can read a certain entity
you can read all entities and you can
put also observer collection and then we
have a so this is this is generic and
not specific for this for the app
the further we have a app specific data
service
it's just roughing this provided it has
what we need to do in this app you can
post a message and we can serve the
messages in the in the fibers database
collection and the implementation of
this is quite simple it takes a day to
provide a factory as a parameter and
then the postal message we get the
provider for messages for that part of
the messages in the database on the path
this is just the messages of the path
from the root own on the on this story
inside this and to observe messages we
just get the same provider the same four
messages on the same path a meeting
observe and it changes to that
connection and that'll be objects added
removed or updated okay that's thus this
is the just recap this is the code we
need to make application specific to be
able to observe an update up collection
in in five s and let me sing
on the on the UI level this is what we
need to react to those observations and
updated and view model for them for the
UI but so that's ya know just a hundred
lines of code altogether it's quite
simple ok back to the slides just to
summarize so what are the lessons
learned in this approach and looks
really promising he had a fairly
cross-platform app in just a few lines
of code with a with a back servlet
backyard you don't really have to do any
provisioning or management or that they
just take care about you need there's
some issues on these providers on the
platform level that was a bit difficult
to do the marshaling of a big values
especially between dotnet and Java was
painful um when we operated somewhere
into the latest version it involved so I
had to down grade to the previous site
below submarine so some issues that I
still have to look further in okay
that's about it
and so thanks
[Applause]